Do you have any good your
mama's so broke jokes?
Your mama's so broke,
she got a sugar daddy.
[ Both laugh ]
[ Laughing ]
That's not funny.
[ Water bubbling ]
Oh, sorry.
I just
only know reality.
And mama's out there
just buying Kias.
What the hell?
Are you all right?
No, I'm high as [bleep]
[ Both laugh ]
Well, Tiffany, you can have
a nice lay-down,
but tell me what to do.
I would just be like,
"Girl, that's your mama."
'Cause you got
to think about it like --
Okay, she stayed in that lady
for nine months, right?
Her mom was pregnant with her
for nine months.
Right.
Okay, now, if you just go
buy a womb -- okay? --
it's like $10,000
for the insemination.
Then,
once the person pregnant,
then I think
it's another $10,000 a month.
The first $10,000,
that was the move-in cost?
That's the move-in fee.
[ Both laugh ]
That's the first
and last months.
It depends on the womb,
but anywhere between
$2,000 and $10,000 a month.
If the mom had to get
a C-section,
does that mean
the daughter
lost her security deposit
on the womb?
-That part.
-Right?
[ Both laugh ]
She messed that pussy up.
So then, she -- she don't
get that $10,000 back.
Oh, my God.
She doesn't get it back
because of damages?
Yes, you're not getting that --
You don't get that back.
That kid's
a little home wrecker.
Yeah.
[ Both laugh ]